Law and Order is nearly extinct in
Liberal cities take San Francisco where
even more businesses are being forced to
pack up and leave high-end retailer
Nordstrom is the latest to close up shop
after 35 years they're going to be
shutting down both stores because of the
Dynamics of its downtown have changed
dramatically sounds like corporate speak
for crimes run us out of town and it's
not safe for our workers and this comes
on the heels of a flagship San Francisco
Whole Foods closing in stores after just
13 months
their place was plagued by violence
drugs vagrants the business made an
astounding 560 emergency calls before
throwing in the towel so far 20 stores
have shut down in the Bay Area since
2020 and the ones that stay are forced
to run what looks like a Maximum
Security Prison to sell deodorant and
toothpaste oh and if you fight back
against this type of insanity
you'll be the one that gets charged
while the criminal gets to scheme
a shoplifter in New York City hit a
Walgreens security guard in the head
with a jar and it was the guard who was
thrown into jail on assault charges and
big surprise the thief failed to show up
to his recent court date Greg San
Francisco guy Nordstroms I'm sure you
dropped a pretty penny there where are
people going to buy high-end clothes
this hurts because this is where my mom
and I would shop uh nor the Nordstrom in
Westfield on Market Street we'd go there
we'd shop we'd go upstairs there's a
restaurant we go there and get drunk and
have fun she'd pay for everything we
take a train back we did whenever I went
into today but I could see how
oppressive that is to have paying
customers right I wish that I wish
Nordstrom's would have called me I would
have I would have told them first just
sell blouses
um loafers and mittens and call yourself
BLM and then the SF Board of Supervisors
will build an iron Rod gate around your
place not to oversell this but this is a
red flag for Western Civilization right
if you want to experiment with left-wing
ideology which doesn't replace anything
but just lets everything self-destruct
here it is they just destroyed the
greatest City ever a city that survived
earthquakes a mayor assassination Mayor
Moscone Harvey Milk the epicenter of
AIDS and it's taken down by Angry white
leftists I mean you cannot get you can't
you cannot let liberals protect or
manage a liberal City we non-liberals
would be happy to do it for you and
still keep it liberal because we love
the cities we love New York we we love
Chicago we love LA and San Francisco let
us in and let us try and let us do it to
an obvious Observer
these are not right-wing companies every
liberal loves Whole Foods and every
white liberal politician buys their
colorful pant suits off the racket
Nordstrom so it's not the right driving
this and it's not the rights ideas this
isn't crooked cops or climate change or
racism that screwed this city it's all
the people that obsess over that that
cost us to happen and if you ask the
White House Corinne will probably say
Nordstrom I thought that was blown up
[Laughter]
nice pipeline material thank you do you
think London breed the mayor of Chicago
is making any effort to retain any of
these businesses because they keep
believing every other week I think they
realize it too late so I I believe that
for a long time people thought that the
wealthy would stay in San Francisco
because it was amazing City and it was
where they were able to go to the
theater and have drinks at one of the
fancy bars get together with friends
have people come into town and then you
can see the ocean everything was great
and then slowly but surely it started
going downhill but still people stayed
and then covet hit and what happened was
when you separate work from your home
life and people realize oh I actually
don't have to be here for my work the
out migration from these cities happened
very very quickly and so even if the
mayor is trying to do something now it's
too late because they didn't stop the
problems with Law and Order in time to
prevent them from leaving so and these
decisions don't come Lightly for a
company like Nordstrom they don't they
won obviously were losing money right
businesses don't close when they're
making a lot of money and everything's
going great they're losing money or
they're not able to protect their staff
not able to keep staff this is one of
the flagship places at that mall so have
you ever seen a mall like when the
flagship leaves what's left Spencer's
Gifts maybe they hold on you got to
appreciate novelty Orange Julius and you
gotta love that but it's not enough to
get a lot of foot traffic to keep coming
in so it's a good warning for other
cities that Sam Francisco realized it
too late hopefully others will not do
the same and we can get to San Francisco
in a second but tell us about this scene
with the security guard so he's trying
to I guess prevent the theft the guy
leaves hits him in the head and he gets
how do they charge no what happens with
the security guard is the guy's stealing
and he says to the guy he says get out
of here the guy comes back a couple
hours later and then hits him in the
head so you know not everybody has the
whole story on this so he hits him in
the head with a jar the guy who's a
security guard then takes him into
custody and they arrest the security
guard which raises a question what is
the security guard supposed to do stand
there and greet criminals and say thanks
for hitting us you know I mean it is
ridiculous but I think that's the Port
Authority we're talking Port Authority
now they're not the brightest cops
around and I'll say it right here now
let me let me be clear about what's
going on here every day in this country
we are descending deeper and deeper into
k us an anarchy it is what is
predictable and it happened because of
the left and the progressives make no
mistake if you end up having no Bail no
cash fail the least restrictive bail you
defund the police you put Discovery
mandates on prosecutors that are so
tough that they have to dismiss murder
cases and you've you're down 600 cops in
San Francisco alone you raise the age of
the criminal you raise the amount of
crime for a theft you're damn right
you're going to get this and every city
in this country is going to end up in
Anarchy and chaos and don't tell me
you're right Dana Nordstrom doesn't want
to leave they didn't put all that money
into the infrastructure and create that
store so they'd have to leave because
some bums and thieves and Dirtbag
criminals decide they want to take down
a city now let's be real clear about one
thing it is the big city with the
Democrat Mayors where they're having
those problem now you can say it's a
Republican states and here's my message
to the Republican Governors if you've
got a big city in your state you better
make sure you get rid of the D.A or else
you're going to be blamed in the next
election as the governor of a red state
where the blue cities are committing all
the crimes and one more thing I want to
say is that the the the the governor has
the right to remove the DA's and if the
governor doesn't do that it's just as
much his fault now Chester Boudin who
was thrown out as the D.A in San
Francisco was replaced by Brooke Jenkins
she's a good D.A but she can't do it
without the cops she can't do it without
the corps course and she can't do it
without the legislature we are going
down
how farther do we have to go
I think this is a good place to level
out it's completely devastating I love
San Francisco
um Dana's right that it's been
deteriorating a long time I was there in
2018 for work my mom came with me to
spend a few days and was followed around
Union Square the shopping center by a
junkie who had a knife who was holding a
knife and we had to duck she didn't
realize what was going on and I was like
you have to make a left here and there
were no police around either not that
we would have necessarily gone right at
that moment because that might have
inspired him to Lunge at her or
something like that but it's felt
dangerous for a while and I visited
during covid and they were shut down
past when we were shut down here when
Chicago other liberal cities and people
who were out in restaurants are sitting
outside in the cold were complaining
like why are we here anymore and it's
going to become a huge money problem for
London breed for the mayor there because
tech companies want their people back at
work so what are you going to do then if
everybody left and they've left for good
reason right this is it uh just you know
I want to see what it's like somewhere
warmer they're moving their families to
somewhere where they feel that it's safe
where the schools were open taxes Etc
they're going to have to figure out some
way to accommodate all of these
high-wage workers that keep the cities
going to make sure that they can go to
the office three four days a week for
these new hybrid schedules in terms of
the shoplifter
it's weird because I would have thought
that having everything on video would
have made this so much easier right and
we say that like thank God there are
things that we saw on video like what
happened with George Floyd right that
changed the course of how we talk about
Criminal Justice Reform in the country
but why when everyone can see with their
two eyes that the security guard was
attacked by this guy knows the story
does it not make any difference in terms
of How It's prosecuted it's almost as if
just turn them all off like what's the
difference at that point and law
enforcement needs to think about that
including the D.A I don't mean just the
streets you're becoming enlightened
right before our eyes yes those videos
don't matter the George Floyd ones those
matter but when it when it happens that
the criminal or a suspect is in the
wrong those things just go away but when
the cops in the wrong you're going to
see that video a hundred times on CNN
and in addition to that this criminal uh
has not been arrested the thief has not
been arrested he'll never be arrested
because they don't have a squad that
goes out that says we're gonna we're
gonna make sure that we've execute
warrants on these people probably one of
those 347 that commit all the crimes the
6 000 arrests and rearrests in a year or
whatever it was yep really good
conversation did you enjoy that Jesse
really good job and I mean that you know
why Jesse you weren't involved you were
just asking questions I agree I think
you're good at that I think it's better
I want to Brian kill Mead I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now